the star hated it the author hated it
and even audiences weren't amused when
it debuted back in 1982. here's the
story of how 40 years later Blade Runner
became regarded as one of the greatest
Sci-Fi movies of all time warning this
video contains Fast Flashing images your
discretion is advised especially for
those with photosensitive epilepsy
do Android's Dream of Electric Sheep is
a hard title to fit on a poster so when
the blade runner team adapted Philip K
Dick's novel it makes sense that they
changed the name but after that it gets
complicated because the term Blade
Runner never even appears in the
original novel instead it dates back to
the Obscure science fiction author
alanie Norris who used knowledge
obtained in his medical doctor day job
to write a dystopian future full of
eugenics and black market Medical Care
in the Blade Runner in this novel Blade
Runners are the middlemen who smuggle
scalpels and other surgical tools to
Rogue doctors which makes sense while I
poured it over to a completely different
future and use it to describe Android
hunting cops well the term for these
middlemen had a crucial middleman of its
own Off the Wall genius William S
Burrows the author of Naked Lunch Burl's
loved Norris's original novel so much
that he wrote a legendarily weird film
treatment of it which found its way into
screenwriter Hampton Ventures Library
when Vander Ridley Scott and producer
Michael Daly were trying to brainstorm a
more unique job title for Deckard in
Dick's book he was just a cop plain and
simple panchered took a look at his
shelves for inspiration there was the
Blade Runner and his problem was solved
Ridley Scott shouldn't have been
available to make Blade Runner if
everything had gone according to plan he
would have been too tied up adapting
Dune in fact when Scott was first
offered the chance to direct Blade
Runner he turned it down it sounded
intriguing but his plate was already
full he was only going to take on one
major science fiction movie at a time
but tragically everything got upended
Frank Scott died of skin cancer and
losing his beloved older brother sent
Ridley Scott into an emotional tailspin
Scott told Vanity Fair I was so down I
needed to do something and dune wouldn't
even go into production for another year
but Blade Runner was still available so
Scott took it on and turned it into an
immortal work of art Scott's grief
shaped Blade Runner in other ways too at
the director series Cameron Beale writes
in this light Scott's approached the
Blade Runner serves as something of a
grieving process for his late brother an
intensely personal work a heartfelt
meditation on creation death and loss
the beauty of Life Is defined by its
ephemerality considered in that light
the film gains even more power and
meaning
how does Blade Runner imagine an utterly
convincing future it draws on the past
especially Hollywood's past pulling from
film Noir to create its own mean La
streets the British film institute's
anatomy of a classic feature on the film
traces some of its Inspirations they
range far and wide even including Edward
Hopper's iconic painting Nighthawks with
its quietly lonely Diner patrons but
Classic Hollywood comes up again and
again one of the best polls is Rachel's
hairstyles and costuming as fashion site
glamamore explains her styling draws
heavily not only on the 1930s and 40s
but on specific films Mildred Pierce and
the Thin Man most of all the film Noir
inspiration shows up in Harrison Ford's
Deckard with his trench coat jaded
decency and semi-outsider Status he's an
old-school hard-boiled detective plain
and simple even deckard's voiceover
often mocked by fans and ultimately
removed from the Final Cut Edition
belongs to this Noir sensibility in fact
even though this exact voiceover track
suffered from Studio mandated dollops of
exposition Ridley Scott liked the basic
idea and even intimate planned on using
one himself screenwriter Hampton vancher
confirmed this in the making of book
future Noir Scott was after the feel of
a 40s detective thriller so he liked the
idea of using this film Noir device all
these familiar movie tropes helped sell
us on this Darkly Strange New World
Edward James almost as enigmatic
character Gaff often speaks in a kind of
linguistic hodgepodge of several real
world languages in the original cut of
the film deckard's voiceover explains
that this lingo is called cityspeak
Lo-Fi
and before almost got his hands on the
script that's about all anyone knew
about it cityspeak was a blank slate
just a funny language placeholder it
caught almost his imagination like a
hook and it seemed like a key part of
gap's character so as he explained in
future Noir the making of Blade Runner
my first idea was to put a mixture of
genuine Spanish French Chinese German
Hungarian and Japanese into City speed
then I went to the berlet school of
languages in Los Angeles translated all
these different bits and pieces of
gaff's original dialogue into fragments
of foreign tongues and learned to
properly pronounce them this futuristic
La language is exactly the kind of World
building that makes Blade Runner one of
the best science fiction movies ever
made
Blade Runner has some of the greatest
sets of all time if we close our eyes we
can see its dark and rainy futuristic
Los Angeles jam-packed with people and
buildings and all the details fit
together perfectly and of course there's
a reason for that a lot of thought went
into the film's production design
especially its architecture as Ridley
Scott explained to American
cinematographer old buildings are
difficult to maintain and when they're
in the middle of urban environments they
can be even more difficult to raise and
rebuild eventually you'll just have to
retrofit things on the face of the
building rather than having to pull half
the side off it's going to be simpler
just to smack things on the outside so
maybe buildings will start to be
designed From the Inside Out you wear
your guts on the outside that gives us a
picture of a textured City and just as
the buildings have gotten more and more
piled on so of the streets which
intentionally evoke a kind of desperate
overcrowding it takes money and a flying
car to go higher and it takes even more
money to build something new tyrell's
700 story pyramid full of polished black
marble it's like an Aztec Temple
reimagined as an office building the
production designer called it a
establishment Gothic and it quickly
signals tyrell's incredible power now
that's some efficient storytelling
when it comes to Blade Runner quotes two
have always stood out Head and Shoulders
Above the Rest gaf's last question to
Deckard it's too bad she won't live
but then again who does
tears and Rain speech Roy Batty makes as
he dies even reading them can give you
chills but what makes him particularly
remarkable is that they were invented by
the actors themselves the British film
institute's anatomy of a classic article
details how rudgar Howard saw Roy as the
hero of the piece and pushed and pushed
for his interpretation Roy is a kind of
embodiment of Charisma and in his words
a romantic flamboyant sexualized Andy
half rock star and half terrorist his
influence over his character and his
persistence in advocating for it led
Scott to give him permission to write
Roy's final speech
right from the start Ridley Scott
insisted that their flying cars had to
be a little different from everybody
else's no plane-like wings or standard
propellers designer Sid Mead told
American cinematographer that the real
challenge wasn't a technical one it was
psychological Mead had to work with what
he calls audience in head memory where
people only believe in something new if
it resonates with what they already know
he worked with that memory partly by
making sure every vehicle we saw matched
up with the world as a whole explaining
for instance you'd start with the air
pollution and you'd say if that's true
then they would probably have to have
bigger air conditioning units more
congested traffic and you get bigger
bumpers they're all familiar ideas
applied in an unconventional way the
same is true for how the vehicles match
their characters J.F Sebastian the
tinkerer has a van that's consciously
designed to look like he pieced it
together himself maybe the audience
doesn't consciously take any of this in
but on all paints a vivid and convincing
picture
making Blade Runner left Harrison Ford
miserable what the hell was happening to
me the Productions continual night
shoots were exhausting and Ridley Scott
who wasn't used to opinionated American
Film Crews had a talent for rubbing
everyone the wrong way but Ford had an
extra complaint he believed very
strongly that Deckard shouldn't be a
replicant in an interview with vanity
fairy said I felt that the audience
needed to have someone on screen that
they could emotionally relate to as
though they were a human being Scott
kept slipping in subtle Clues to
undermine this it was a major artistic
standoff and neither one of them could
let it go the film was also a sore spot
for a while because it initially flopped
in hindsight we can certainly see that
it didn't hurt for its career but it
must have felt like it at the time all
in all we can see why it all left Ford
pretty sour but we're glad that the
film's lasting cultural Legacy has
brought him around on it he and Scott
mended fences and Ford returned for
Blade Runner 2049 Which Scott executive
produced
Blade Runner was such a distinctive
ambiguous and ambitious film that it was
right from the start in danger of being
a flop so Guided by early test
screenings Ridley Scott decided to
inject a little more optimism into the
ending the 1982 release accordingly
featured Deckard and Rachel making their
getaway into the mountains transitioning
from the Noir cityscape to a kind of
idyllic Untamed nature where it's
possible they can find some kind of
Peace but most of the footage they
captured at Big Bear Lake was marred by
bad weather when you're desperately
trying to inject a little more hope into
your ending you know what you don't want
heavy ominous clouds luckily Scott
remembered the famous opening of Stanley
Kubrick's The Shining or the camera
Glides over the mountains to follow the
torrance's car in context it's
unsettling out of context it's gorgeous
and while Kubrick didn't want to turn
over any shots he'd actually used he was
fine with Supply and Scott with his
outtakes it's a clever solution provided
the audience doesn't know about the
substitution no one wants to think that
Deckard and Rachel are inadvertently
fleeing towards the Overlook Hotel
Philip K dick and Blade Runner got off
to a bad start in an interview with the
Twilight Zone magazine dick explained
that his dealings with Hollywood left a
bad taste in his mouth he didn't trust
the studio and he didn't like the Blade
Runner script he thought Hampton
fancher's original screenplay cleaned
the book up of all of the subtleties and
of the meaning and it upset him to feel
like his work was being stripped of its
real substance seeing a promo of the
movie's special effects turned things
around the visuals boggled him he said I
recognized it immediately it was my own
interior world that caught it perfectly
I've
seen things you people wouldn't believe
ironically this was exactly the change
of heart he'd been worried he would have
beforehand his agent had urged him to go
see the remarkable sets and [ __ ]
refused saying if the sets are that good
maybe I'll go up there and fall into the
mode that exists now in science fiction
or the special effects and the sets are
everything while he didn't go that far
but the sets were good so they prompted
him to ask for a copy of the new
screenplay and the adjustments won him
over completely unfortunately dick died
a few months before the movie's release
he was never able to see it's in full
but we're glad it still wound up giving
him some Joy
we're all used to the story of the
classic film that bombs at the box
office and only picks up its true
audience later on it's happened before
and it'll happen again and to be fair
the original cut of Blade Runner was
burdened with tacked on happy and
lackluster voiceovers they don't
advertise for killers in a newspaper
that was my profession if you prefer the
more ambiguous later additions you might
understand why theater goers in 1982
mostly gave this one a Miss but they
also gave it a Miss because it opened in
June of 1982 which was absolutely
swamped with competing sci-fi features
nearly all of which have proved
memorable in their own right Blade
Runner already burdened with lackluster
reviews was coming into theaters that
were already packed for showings of E.T
and Star Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan and
even audiences who want a darker fare
could have flocked to Poltergeist or
John Carpenter's superbly chili the
thing which opened directly opposite
Blade Runner it was a month jam-packed
with destined Classics and plenty of
audiences understandably opted for the
more familiar and comforting
entertainment of Spielberg and Star Trek
when you want to watch Blade Runner you
have to make a choice which Blade Runner
exactly as it turns out there are seven
different versions of Blade Runner and
these aren't as buried as the original
versions of Star Wars either you can
still get your hands on several older
versions of Blade Runner especially if
you shell out for the collector's
edition DVDs but for most fans it comes
down to a battle between the original us
theatrical cuts and Ridley Scott's Final
Cut from 2007. both have their merits
for example the original is the version
that cemented the movie's place in
history no one would have ever cared
about the Final Cuts if they hadn't
already been hooked by the original it's
also not like the Final Cut represents
some kind of pristine artistic Purity
after all it's not just a cut free of
Studio interference it contains out and
out reshoots the Final Cut is a
masterpiece of ambiguity with all the
original virtues of the film sharpened
and Polished you lose the clunky
narration and you get a much more
convincing haunting ending there's no
wrong answer here in both versions like
humans and replicants are equally real
thank you